okay so this is literally so stressful
everything has plastic and the
anticipation is killing me
hey my name's emmy i live in tokyo japan
hey i'm may i live in hollywood
california and
for the next 72 hours i'm gonna do my
absolute best
to be zero waste japan loves plastic
one of the main hurdles is trying to
avoid plastic because it is literally
everywhere i think doing this is gonna
be a big eye-opener for me i'm gonna try
my best
for sure i really don't know i'm nervous
for the next three days
okay so day one i was like oh my god i'm
gonna go get breakfast i have my daily
routine of eating my
oatmeal i can't be using this package
yeah i live like right down the street
from this
restaurant that actually has these like
grab-and-go breakfast things that come
in a glass container
and then bring it back i feel like this
whole entire
three days is going to be a lot of
realizing that like
taking the easy way out it's not always
the best
welcome to my bathroom
i'm joking this is a hotel bathroom
pretty much all of japan has
stopped using um hand dryers
this is my first piece of trash i was so
excited about this zero waste breakfast
and then i opened it and i realized
there's a plastic container for granola
so
i guess we have gotten our first thing
of waste so i got lunch before leaving
osaka
but there was plastic wrapped around the
napkins
and the kusyakin it came with wooden
skewers
so yeah i had to take that back home
something that i do not think about at
all until this exact moment right now
i just sneezed and i went to grab a
tissue
and i can't use one like that is garbage
tmi
but i did have to wash my hands let's
get back from the supermarket
they do use so much plastic
this this is the problem like why
does one carrot need to be individually
wrapped in plastic
this one bell pepper now broccoli
they did have it just like this but you
need to put it in a plastic bag
it's like essentially the same thing you
just don't get a gold sticker
everything has plastic i'm trying to hit
the grocery store the least amount of
times possible
my roommates and i have kind of been
doing this thing where we all go at the
same time
i'm going grocery shopping tomorrow that
means today i have to figure out how to
eat without having any waste i had this
idea there's a
really kind of fancy grocery store but
last time i was there i
actually saw they had these glass
containers i hope it's not
too expensive and then you can give it
to them and they'll fill it up with food
from the hot bar and you can take it
home and reuse it
i made dinner with the groceries that i
got from the supermarket
i'm not the type of person that eats the
leaves from the broccoli so i kind of
snip those off
i usually peel the carrot skins but i
just decided to try it unpeeled so
overall i think i did
okay um it's mostly vegetable peels
i found this which i thought would be
a much better idea than buying two
liters of green tea
every single time and we'll make some
green tea
there's already little particles all
right so after calling like literally
five different restaurants everybody
said that they can't use reusable
containers right now
it is back to using this i'm back to the
same grocery store that i was just at
but
it's better than like wasting the bag
and the container and the utensils and
whatever
the environment
wow okay so i subconsciously pulled out
this face mask
to relax but then it's trash now
how do i preserve this like i'm not okay
with this
that's terrifying
[Music]
if this isn't a fit i don't know it is i
hope the starbucks braces
okay we're literally next in line and
the anticipation is killing me
are you guys able to use reusable cups
right now
so that was a bust how does it feel
i love the environment i just i need
caffeine
i'm gonna roast my chickpeas on this
it'll eventually become trash but at
least
i'll be able to use the paper again for
a different meal for lunch i had a
chickpea salad sandwich and i ended up
with
a couple of vegetable scraps and the
plastic
around the bell pepper all right so we
are getting ready to go grocery shopping
for just like our everyday stuff and
then also for this picnic that we're
gonna try and make zero waste
we have like little reusable bags for
our produce and then we're also bringing
our own paper bags that we have saved
from like previous grocery shopping
we're doing okay
like come on i didn't even ask for this
i'm gonna fill this water bottle with
the green tea that i made
so that i don't have to keep buying
these whenever i get thirsty
normally this is what we would get but
uh
not today not today not the easy way out
today ladies
no hot food what i decided to do
is i just got a sandwich they wrap it in
paper so at least it's recyclable so i
guess it's like
lesser evil it's on her paper sad
everything was in plastic like every
single thing we couldn't even buy like
chips or crackers or anything
no chips for me okay so these are the
bags that we brought so that's what i'm
gonna be using
and i think we're just gonna put
everything in the cart bring it out to
our car and then bag it there since
you're not allowed to bring reusable
bags in the store right now
i may not have thought this through
but in the moment did me dirty like
what am i supposed to do with this so
we're gonna go down there
set up and have a fun time
literally every single thing had
stickers on it so we have to keep that
but we didn't get pre-cut fruit
sacrifice a little bit
okay so literally wrapped in one piece
of paper wrapped in another piece of
paper
we got plastic we have
also two pieces of paper but you know
what
it's a nice day out we're not gonna be
mad
all right so i'm about to make dinner
and i'm
shamefully admitting the amount of
plastic
that comes with it plastic plastic
plastic
plastic and styrofoam i don't know
man so for dinner i made a simple
japanese meal
with gam mo it's kind of tofu i guess
eggplant
and steamed salmon usually
you would wrap it in aluminum foil but
i'm
reusing the cooking paper that i used
for the chickpeas earlier
sunscreen is not that fragile i feel
nope oh wait hold on we got one more
great it's only been two days like it
really shouldn't be that hard i feel
like
also i decided i'm not gonna go out or
anything for dinner i think my
roommate's gonna cook something and i'll
probably just eat leftovers from
that and it's the best i can do right
now i have all this
waste maybe i can make some green dye
out of this like if i'm gonna throw it
out anyways i might as well make the
most of it
ew and i'm gonna try
and dye this white rag my expectations
are extremely low
this is the day my confidence is up
we're going to farmer's market we're
gonna get fresh produce
no plastic i'm in reusable bags i buy
the packs
of spaghetti that already have this
taste so i guess
this is trash i made this vegetarian
pasta dish
and it really didn't make as much trash
as i
thought it would so this has been
sitting in this
die for about 20 hours now like it has
some earthy tones
so after washing it a couple of times
it's pretty cute
i've been in this farmer's market before
and i know that they have so many things
not
any packaging no stickers no nothing
i mean that's probably good thank you a
lot of sun and a lot of sweat later
i have enough food to last me for the
day and i'm actually so excited i have a
really fun recipe in mind
i got everything that i needed and
honestly i feel like it was cheaper than
going to the grocery store
once again i'm showing off the amount of
plastic
that i'll be throwing away at the end of
the day i don't
i'm sorry i would peel the skin off
but i'm not gonna do that today i think
i'll just cut
like a tiny sliver but other than that i
will be using the whole thing
i got a spaghetti squash i got a bunch
of tomatoes to make like a fresh
homemade sauce like
it's gonna be so good i want her
so bad i'm in my kitchen and we're about
to cook dinner
so i'm making spaghetti squash and then
making a homemade sauce with the
tomatoes
onion and shallots that i got i'm really
excited because i'm
really hungry so chef mae is here
and we're gonna cook i feel like i
should not be dressed with a knife this
big but
i'm the strongest person alive so thank
you
this looks interesting instead of making
a real sauce we're gonna make more of
like a a fresh tomato sauce if you will
a candy's bad but i don't think it's
going to be like quite the spaghetti
sauce that i was hoping for
yikes but also we're working with what
we have
like parser shaped it does look like
holy [ __ ] this is definitely the most
successful meal thus far
when i get out of the shower i like to
eat ice cream but i'm trying not to make
any crash
so i'm eating an orange instead if they
give me the idea
of using the orange peels and making
those
sort of sugar coated orange peel
thingies that you see in gift shops and
stuff
oh my god oh my god i'm so proud
all the possibilities
[Music]
so i just woke up which means 72 hours
and no waste are over i feel terrible
because i did
such a bad job i did try i really did
japan loves plastic there are things
that i can do better
like you know not buying plastic bottles
it's like bringing my own water bottle
everywhere
don't get zero waste but i did honestly
get pretty close like i have a whole new
perspective on like my own behavior that
i didn't have before so
taking a step back really looking at
what you're doing
what you can change and how you can be
better even if it's in small ways is
so important i'll do better i did have
fun making these
and this so not a total bummer
[Music]
you